and today we examined in detail the
steps that our
relevant department needs to take in
order to prevent any damage
to our economic relations and
achieve their reconfiguration in the new
conditions that are caused by illegitimate
unilateral sanctions of the United States and its
allies, but in the current shadow conditions, the
legitimate sanctions that were imposed
which prevented
operations with Russian grain, including
insurance, including calls to ports by
our ships, foreign ports and calls by
foreign ships, Russian ports,
now after the signing of the agreement in
Istanbul on the initiative
of the UN Secretary General, he volunteered to seek the
removal of these illegitimate
restrictions, we will hope that
he will succeed, but  regardless of
this, we have an understanding of how to work
on the full implementation of contracts between the
Russian Federation and our
Egyptian colleagues why